welcome to CBS this morning we're very
happy to say that Anthony Mason is not
here today why because if you're
watching us yesterday you know Tony
yes his voice was a little froggy his
voice was fading by the end of the two
hours he had no voice but we are in good
hands always good to have Jericka Duncan
at the table we're gonna begin with this
a powerful winter storm system is behind
a spring-like tornado outbreak in the
deep south people in Louisiana
Mississippi and Alabama or cleaning up
after a deadly string of at least 27
tornadoes ripped up the homes and tore
through neighborhoods there at least
three people were killed including a
husband and his wife
this happened in northwestern Alabama
all these storms were part of a powerful
winter weather front bringing snow and
ice to the Northeast this morning after
dumping heavy snow in parts of the
Midwest the system is blamed for at
least 12 other deaths our lead national
correspondent David Beck know is in
Alexandria Louisiana that is outside a
damaged school I can see behind him
there damaged by a tornado David good
morning what are you seeing doesn't look
good Tony this is the Hope Baptist
Church and school that section where the
roof is gone that was the school you had
kids as young as four years old who were
in there during the noon hour they took
the kids from the school to the church
which still has the roof and if you look
over here that's where the mangled cross
and signage for the school now is this
supposed to be green lawn now littered
with debris get this this tornado that
started in Southwest Louisiana and moved
to the Northeast was 63 miles on the
ground unheard of 63 miles that one
tornado was on the ground moving the
whole time this is what people saw
across Louisiana and Mississippi Monday
afternoon I don't know look life might
be turning this away there were at least
27 tornadoes and all it was a rare
outbreak in December that ripped apart
homes and businesses across the south
from above you can see widespread damage
for many homes nothing was left standing
but the studs in Alexandria Louisiana
most of this school and daycare was
shredded piles of sheet metal and wood
are now in the front yard just ten
minutes before that tornado hit teachers
led 18 students who were inside the
school to the church next door
or after they received the alert about
the tornado the students took shelter
under the pews afterward Fire Rescue
crews wrapped the students in towels and
blankets and walked them away from the
wreckage in Vernon Parish Louisiana
betty pata died after her trailer
overturned just one day after her 59th
birthday she just wonder what the world
things happen because the mic could be
going just a second you can see it was
common and you can feel it she kind of
shaped the house about 130 miles
northeast of here another twister
battered the small town of Edwards
Mississippi in gun town Mississippi this
Baptist Church was destroyed after a
tornado touched down here it was one of
at least 35 structures damaged in
Guntown according to a police dispatcher
several people were injured the
conditions were not known this morning
last night emergency response teams
searched for people who may be
underneath the rubble as the city
remained dark without power
in gun town they're gonna have to wait
until daylight to see just how bad the
damage is gun town is just north of
Tupelo Mississippi
Jericka here in Alexandria this system
is also brought with it winter weather I
got to tell you I was at home with
family getting ready for the Christmas
break in Lafayette Louisiana about an
hour to the west of here yesterday we
were wearing flip-flops and
short-sleeved t-shirts and today we're
dressed appropriately like it's winter
yeah I can tell it's cold out there
David thank you so much